the trailer for Captain America finally
out and worth talking about so in the
Captain America trailer we see Steve
Jobs Rogers yes Steve Jobs he gets the
Super Soldier Serum that's why we have
iPhones we see Steve Rogers who's really
skinny pale and just really sickly it's
really weird to see Johnny Storm looked
like me from high school he can't looks
like that dude from the new guy who
wants to join the army but the Army's
like no and so then he's told that he
might be perfect for the super soldier
program that gives us captain murder
propaganda for the win and I like how
this movie seemingly plays off that I
mean everyone knows Captain America was
a propaganda piece and in the movie they
seemed to make him a propaganda piece
we're in the red white and blue and
whatnot although he's Captain America
see who does look like it has practical
application the material looks like it's
army gear not like polyester yeah this
is horrible and I really like how the
movie does take place in World War 2 it
would have been really easy for the
studio to be like alright we need to
make it relevant in modern so make it
you know Iraq but they didn't its World
War 2 that's where it should take place
so good job Marvel Studios after the
first half of the trailer which I think
will probably sum up the first third of
the movie we see guns and flamethrowers
and throwing shields classic Captain
America Stubb best part of the trailer
is this part right here boom they kick
in the door and start slugging guys like
yeah you you kept you - yeah you're dead
that's classic America right there we
all think that we can actually kick open
a door and start plugging people look
he's not even guarding his face with his
shield he's like yeah I gotta guard that
you know left PEC he's probably wearing
Kevlar so you know you never be too safe
with your left pack they could have
summed up the trailer in that three
seconds right there just like America
coming soon and we get a flash of the
Red Skull and with technology out there
we go threes frame he looks cool he's no
weaving and anything is cool then we
have hardcore sergeant Tommy Lee Jones
talking in his own every dog house
henhouse outhouse whorehouse you know
Tommy Lee Jones voice oh I think it's
gonna be perfect for this movie then we
have Stanley Tucci who's a great actor
if you've ever seen a review for a okay
mediocre movie but Stanley Tucci was in
it rest assured the review said well
Stanley Tucci was the best part of the
movie at least mine say that so good
actors awesome action taking place in
world war ii where it belongs with some
good old america propaganda Captain
America looks like win I don't think
it's gonna be as good as Iron Man I
don't think any of these Avengers movies
are gonna be as good as the first Iron
Man but it looks cool although British
chicks are pretty careless
I think it was what if that she'll
didn't work I mean you just killed
Captain America hot British chick we
forgive you the government probably will
not though America so I say the movie
looks cool and this summer's really
shaping up to be really good so what do
you think of the Captain America trailer
comment below let me know I put a link
below for the trailer also if you want
to check it out if you haven't already I
don't want to give a shout-out to a guy
his name is Joe al I hope I'm
pronouncing that right dude I suck with
name pronunciations who is he will in
the u reviewers movie awards we were
stuck in a pinch something fell through
that shouldn't have fallen through we
didn't have any category title so we had
about a day to find someone who can make
them in a day and Joe al came through so
props to you man you are a badass that
you reviewers movie awards couldn't have
happened the way it did without you and
you're going to heaven just saying and
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more